pas
[Musique]
mais cela on peut les remettants
détendre pour une fois il n'y a pas
d'urgence à gérer ce matin au milieu de
leur stock de matériel patrick et ses
deux collègues d'actifs doucement il
doit préparer les charges et quelques
fauteuils pour une animation en milieu
carcéral entre réparation et mise à
disposition ses techniciens travaillent
souvent dans le monde adore la nation
quand des gens descendent pas ça va de
l'électricité de la plomberie la
maintenance de véhicules
c'est variable en fonction de ce que les
interventions des fois on trouvera de
faire choir en faire autre chose parce
que on fait l'urgence quoi en premier
du côté du restaurant
l'urgence c'est trois fois par jour
quand les sportifs débarquent par vagues
matin midi et soir
on fournit 120 à 150 repas par service
des plats et des aliments adaptés aux
jeunes athlètes du creps qui doivent
gérer leur alimentation eux mêmes pour
les plus jeunes au départ on est
vraiment sur l'éducation à la nutrition
donc on va essayer de faire que déjà
leur alimentation soit équilibré qui ait
pas trop de deux dérapages on va dire
dans la semaine aussi bien sur les choix
des aliments que sur les quantités quand
ils grandissent oui comment savoir que
l'alimentation peut avoir un impact sur
la performance est là on commence à
optimiser
l'année dernière fois je résiste
optimiser la performance améliorer la
résistance vaste mission placée entre
les mains de l'équipe médicale qui n'est
podologue psychologue cardiologue et
même chirurgien traumatique
ils sont neuf au service des sportifs
s'étaient mis en insuffisance d'appui
gauche est ton cerveau il est bloqué là
dessus si on peut dire donc il va
falloir reconditionnés dans le système
pour qu'il fonctionne d'une manière
beaucoup plus équilibrée de la
récupération à la rééducation
chaque athlète est suivi de près tout au
long de l'année par ces spécialistes
choisis pour leur expertise
on a fait des choix quant aux robots
intervenant en cardiologie en
traumatologie chirurgie orthopédique
médecine générale médecine du sport
parce qu'on a des bons à identifier des
besoins dans les disciplines qu'on avait
présente sur le creps mais aussi parce
qu'on a identifié les besoins dans le
cadre de l'accès à la haute performance
que l'objectif est quand même là c'est
la performance n'est plus explicitement
la haute performance et la préparation à
l'autre partance pour viser haut
le creps centre val de loire a longtemps
été précurseur en matière médicale
on y travaille en équipe avec autant
d'exigences que de bienveillance